if
here
Good morning again church. If you have your copy of
God's word turn with me to Luke 14. Luke chapter
14 is where we will be studying today
versus 25 through 33. Let's go
ahead and find that as we get into it today.
We're continuing our series through Jesus's parables in the
Book of Luke where we are going to be confronted again
today with the reality of what it means to
be a kingdom citizen.
Where the values of God's kingdom are many ways
opposite to what the way of the world is.
Getting into it today though. I want to take you back about 16 months
ago.
To a time in my life that I believe has changed my
life forever.
See was a Wednesday night a long day of ministry
up here and I get home and and I feel this low grade
dizziness.
So I thought well, it's just like exhaustion. I'm gonna
go to bed and wake up tomorrow be all fine. But over
the next couple days, it just got steadily worse.
To where that Sunday? I couldn't be here. Brett had to fill in last minute to
preach.
And that dizzy feeling would come and go over the
next couple weeks where at times it would be really really bad at
times. It would be almost disappearing but it all
came to a head that first week of April.
Easter week
We're on that Wednesday. I was in the ER right across
the street here.
Because it was so bad. I couldn't function we thought maybe
I've got a tumor we're doing CT scans. We just don't know what it
is trying to figure it out.
I had to miss Good Friday that week up here
and
it's just a terrible few days, but I was not missing
Easter Sunday, right? That's like the Super Bowl for us.
And so I was here had someone pick
me up and drive me here that morning and I was so
unstable that I had to sit in a chair low chair
right here to preach.
My head was tilted about five degrees off because my
brain was off and and I got up and I stumbled off
like I was on a cruise ship walking off the stage after
I was done.
I think we're not totally sure what it was.
But we think it was a virus that landed in my inner ear and kind
of blew up your balance system and that finally tuned system that it is.
But let me just give you a glimpse of how terrible it was for
those stretches of time during those weeks.
Last year, so I'm laying there in
the room feels like it's spinning around me.
My eyes were tracking movement that wasn't
there.
Because I couldn't stop it.
Thankfully those stretches of time after
Easter Sunday just began to slowly fade away
where I started in a chair and then you know
next week. I was in a stool and then over the course of
that summary. It was like a stool and I was standing some and then sitting some
and it was fun to watch the dynamic some kids. Hey, you're
standing more today like that kind of thing as up here.
To where now? I feel
completely normal in that
so praise the Lord for that but here's why I share
all that see many of you walked with us through that. So I
want to say thank you again for helping serve our family
through that many of you are new no nothing about that at
all. And so this is all news but here's why I share that.
Seeing those stretches where I'm laying flat on my back.
Couldn't move without feeling I was gonna lose my lunch right?
I couldn't do anything.
I got to a pretty dark place.
I mean I couldn't sleep.
I couldn't watch TV I couldn't read.
I couldn't play with my sons. I couldn't do
anything.
I couldn't distract myself from the chaos that
was going on in my body and in my life at
the time.
So I'm just laying there in my thoughts in my
fears. Haven't slept for days. Wondering am
I ever gonna work again?
Like will I ever be able to drive a car again or was spinning
coming on will I ever be useful at home?
Watching my sons.
Uncertain about the future because they've never seen me really suffer like
that. I can't do anything and my wife carrying such an incredibly
heavy burden for that stretch of time where I couldn't help.
Like it was the most emotionally draining time
of my life.
Shed many tears.
wrestling internally with that
but here's what Jesus did through that.
in me
you remember seeing those like crime detective
TV shows or movies where?
Where they're bringing the perpetrator in for questioning?
And they bring him in this little room and there's one little table with one little
light bulb sitting right up hanging up above it and there's the
chair for the detective and then there's the chair
for the perpetrator the detectives asking questions and it's just
that scene right you get that scene in your head.
That's what Jesus did with me.
As I imagine him I can almost visualize what
I felt in that moment where I'm I'm sitting there.
He sits me down across the table everything else
in my life is Stripped Away. I have no distractions.
I can't distract my mind. I can't
do anything and Jesus almost audibly
asked me the question in that setting.
Am I enough for you?
If you get none of that back.
If you can never preach again.
If you can't work.
If you have to be driven everywhere, if you have to take medicine your whole
life. If you can't work out like you did before you can't play with your sons.
If you can't do any of that I if none of
that ever comes back, Jesus asks me.
Am I enough for you?
Is Jesus enough?
transparently
I'd never really had to answer that question before.
I've always had enough.
Like I've never been to the end of myself like that where
I had nothing else.
Well, it's fully dependent on him and even on others
in that moment, where where I was unable to
do anything.
There's a piercing question.
But I want you to hear me today.
Jesus is asking every single one of
us that same question.
Is he enough for you?
Is Jesus enough?
Or is it? Yes, Jesus as
long as I have this to.
As long as I have enough money as long as I don't
suffer too bad as long as
I have some Comforts to or is
Jesus.
enough
It's the question. He asked me.
Continually asks me that's the question. He asks here
in Luke 14.
Starting in verse 25 look at what he says to the crowds here.
Now great crowds accompanied Jesus and he turned and
said to them if anyone comes to me and does
not hate his own father and mother and wife and children and
brothers and sisters. Yes and even his own life.
He cannot be my disciple.
Whoever does not bear his own cross and come after me
cannot be my disciple.
For which of you Desiring to build a tower
does not first sit down and count the cost.
Whether he has enough to complete it.
Otherwise when he has laid a foundation is not able to
finish all who see it begin to mock him.
Saying this man began to build and was not able to finish.
Or what king going out to encounter? Another king in
war will not sit down first and deliberate whether
he is able with 10,000 to meet him who comes against him
with 20,000.
And if not while the others he had a great way off. He sends
a delegation asked for terms of peace.
So therefore any one of you who does not renounce all that.
He has cannot be my disciple Jesus.
We need you today.
These are hard words.
open our ears to hear open our eyes to see
open our hearts to receive your
word for us today
Don't let us temper this run away from this God. May
we face this?
full on
with what you want to teach us and change in
us today For Your Glory.
And Jesus name we pray amen.
So, let me give you a memorable way to to
think about what Jesus is teaching here
in this passage.
The idea that you can walk away with that you see
him teaching here is that Jesus wants followers not
fans.
There's a well-known book that talks about this. But but that's the
idea here. Jesus wants followers not fans. Now.
You understand the difference, right?
a fan
is someone who likes maybe even loves the
team?
But it's not a hundred percent invested.
Right, they are up in the stands. They stay up in
the stands. In fact, many many fans will even turn
on you.
Be critical when it doesn't go their way.
I know this first hand in 2001 homecoming against, Colorado.
Everybody loved the trick play that I completed the
long pass and there's a play of the game and all of that.
But then at the end of the game when I dropped a pass on the game-winning Drive.
They were yelling at me like I was worthless.
See a fan.
Not only gets critical but a fan
leaves early when the game's not in hand and
they don't they don't see the end result. They don't like the results
and so they leave.
bail
A follower though is like a player actually on the team committed to
the team involved in the team sinks with
the team win losing full on and Rises with
the team win winning full on.
Because they are a hundred percent committed to
it.
And here with this Parable and all of The Parables
Jesus is separating those two groups. He
separating fans from followers. What he's doing is he's getting
people to think about the reason they're following him.
But also think about the cost involved to follow him.
And so what we consider today as we also inherent
In this passage is this same call to
us today to follow him. Like he
was implying for those who are following him in that moment.
So as we hear the call to follow Jesus we are
reminded of his invitation.
This invitation to follow him is all
over the gospels Matthew Mark Luke and John, in fact
22 times. At least the words follow me
come out of Jesus's mouth in those Gospels.
Where he's either talking to a person he's talking to
a group or just in general. He's talking to his disciples that this
was what people should do is saying follow me.
Follow me was his invitation that's really
to Jesus the essence of of lordship
and salvation to him that that we are
saved not to a theological principle. We're saved
to a person.
Not just mental beliefs. We're saved to
Jesus. In fact, that's the word disciple what it means is follower.
So these Disciples of Jesus they were merely followers which
means to follow someone around
a disciple followed someone here. Jesus could
be a number of different rabbis a follower
of that person was also learning how
to imitate that person to do what they did
to say what they say think like they thought so a disciple
is a follower
An imitator so we talk about disciple making around here
a lot.
What we mean by that is we are helping someone learn
how to imitate Jesus. It's simple that's
all we're talking about. It's not some theological teaching
and all the depth of that that's part of it, but it's not
just that it's also saying here's how you love someone.
Let me show you that's how Jesus did it. So let's how
this is how we should do it as well. So there's
this call that we see to us even today
to follow Jesus, but as we've seen here some stipulations.
To following Jesus right there. There's a cost involved
here. We must count that cost to follow
Jesus.
As we hear the call, let's not forget the cost. Imagine again.
Jesus sitting across that table
from you.
from me
and he says these words here in Luke
14 and he says that to you and
you're thinking the same thing that I'm thinking as I'm
reading this here, like now wait a second Jesus hold up.
What you're telling me here is that I have to hate
my family.
You're telling me that I have to die on a
cross to follow you.
That I got to sell everything. I have to go live under a bridge. Is that
is that what you're saying Jesus that I have to do that to
follow you?
And it sounds radical. That's why we temper this
right we kind of say let's not really what he meant. It's not the only time he
said this.
In fact in Luke chapter 9 where he
had just told them he's going to die on
a cross. He said this if anyone would come after me
let him deny himself and take up his cross daily and follow
me.
For whoever would save his life will lose it. But whoever loses
his life for my sake will save it.
For what? Does it profit of man if he gains the whole world and loses or
forfeits himself?
And listen, he was serious about that because of what he says next in
verse 26. He says whoever is ashamed of me and
of my words of him will
the son of man be ashamed when he comes in his glory.
What he means is that what I just said, you better take it seriously.
Pick up your cross die. I mean what I say
that there's a cost to follow Jesus.
see True Discipleship requires total
dedication
But even as we say this, there's one at least one way we
can get confused on this.
Again, we hear these words.
Jesus do you literally mean we have to hate our families
and our stuff?
It's Jesus. Do you do you mean I hate my wife?
Here's where understanding Jewish culture is helpful.
because when they would use the word hate
they didn't use it. Like we think of bitterness and anger
and all that involved in hatred. They didn't use it that
way.
They used it in a way that it was just that you loved something
else so much more.
That you loved this comparatively so much
that it seems like you hate the
rest of it.
In fact, Jesus says it this way in Matthew 10, whoever loves father
or mother more than me is not worthy
of me. It's what he says here Luke 14 just in
a little different way. Whoever loves son or daughter more than me is
not worthy of me. That's what he's saying is you
love me so much that it
seems like you hate.
your family
Means what Jesus was saying in Luke 14, was that him being in
first place in your life. Totally overwhelms
the natural love you have for your family
members.
I served on staff with a man in Stillwater at a
church and and as he left that church he moved
him and his family to Southeast Asia.
To be missionaries to an unreached people group there.
They had multiple kids when they left they had multiple kids
over there. They now have nine. And so that was quite
the sight walking around Southeast Asia.
But I remember him telling me something after he had announced that they
were called to move over there and he had someone come
up to him.
And ask him this question to his face.
Do you hate your kids?
And we got a chuckle about that a little bit. But but what they meant by
that question.
Was that he was taking them out of the Safety and Security of
America?
And he was taking them and depriving them from the convenience
and Comforts that we have here.
He was moving them away from family and from Friends.
And on and on we could go do you hate your kids?
And what he told me in that conversation.
Was that when we obey Jesus as we
should?
It will probably look like to the world that
we really do hate our family.
It will appear like we are depriving or
hurting them. We hate them in reality. It's just that we
love Jesus so much more than all of this.
And the way that we best love our family is by
following him wholeheartedly.
That's actually the right way to love your family
is to put him first.
And if he calls he calls and you go and they
see that.
That Jesus is king of your life.
It's the absolute best way.
Even to the point where Jesus says here. We must be willing if
he calls to give up our very
lives.
Now he might not ask that of you.
But I think it's healthy at times to consider.
If he does ask that of you.
Are you willing?
If he puts you in a situation where you have to
give your life for him, are you
willing?
Because remember the cross he asked us to pick up.
is an instrument of death
so he says do that.
Would you be willing because when he was saying that to his hearers they
fully understood what he meant.
Because maybe earlier that day or maybe the
week before or the month before they had heard Roman
soldiers. Look at someone and say take up your
cross and follow me.
So they knew when Jesus said take up your cross and
follow me. They understood that meant effectively.
I must consider myself already dead.
It's the best illustration of self-denial.
It's not my life.
I've died Galatians 2:20 crucified with Christ. I no
longer live Christ lives in me. I have given it up.
for him
I've already chosen to die to myself. Jesus
says it like this in John 12. He says whoever loves his
life clings to his life loses it.
Whoever hates his life in this world meaning loves
Jesus more than this
life. Whoever hates his life in this world will keep it.
for eternal life
See, that's what I wrestled with last year.
That if I'm going to follow Jesus wholeheartedly like
he calls me to then I must not
Place ultimate value on anything else
that him.
Everything else is secondary.
To living for him to obey him to
worshiping him it all comes second. Even
the good things in life even even my own physical life.
It all comes secondary to his Pursuit.
And then Jesus told these two Parables that that don't lower the
bar in any way, right?
Remember what they said?
and Luke 14
Which of you Desiring to build a tower does not first
sit down and count the cost.
Whether he has enough to complete it.
Otherwise when he's laid a foundation is not able to finish all who
see it begin to mock him saying this man began to
build is not able to finish like look at how nice this Foundation looks that's
it.
Or what king going out to encounter? Another king
in war will not sit down first and deliberate whether he is able with
10,000 to meet whom who comes against him with twenty
thousand and if not while the other is yet a great way
off. He sends a delegation asked for terms of Peace. He's not able to meet
that. So he says man, I got to protect myself and limit my damage
here, so I'm going
So you look at this.
and you think
What's the dominant word that Jesus uses over and
over and over in that Passage?
It's the word Abel.
You see it here verse 29 is he able to
finish?
Verse 30 is he able to finish verse 31
is he able with 10,000 to go
against 20,000 verse 32. It's implied. He's not able to go
against that big army. And so he asked for peace
even verse 28 does he have enough to complete
it? That's talking ability, right?
That word able in fact is related to the original Greek
word. Dunamis many of you know that word
already where it's it's the word for power.
It's where we get our English word Dynamite happens to
be on July 4th weekend. I didn't plan that but but you see like the point
is the power able to
do it. In fact the word that's negative of that is
the same word cannot be in those same
verses.
When Jesus said in verse 27, you cannot be my disciple. It's the same
word.
Able to do this able to do this cannot be
so you look at verse 27 a little differently.
Whoever does not bear his own cross and come
after me is not able to be my disciple.
does not have the power the capacity the capability
to be
and that's the fundamental question. Jesus asking the
crowd.
asking us
Are you able to follow me?
The word Abel over and over that's the power that
dunamis power like the capacity. Are you
able
to follow Jesus
Do you have the power to follow Jesus?
now theologically
we understand.
none of us are
there's not one of us who has the
ability in our dead sinful selves to
follow him. We cannot do it. Our
hearts must be awakened by faith to his
grace for us giving us new hearts that then
want to follow him want to give up everything for him. It
starts with God.
But what Jesus was doing with these parables?
Was he was weeding out the fans who
might merely be attracted to him
for the benefits that he offers.
In fact, there's an illustration of this in John chapter 6 where Jesus
had just fed the 5,000 with a Hebrew Happy Meal. Everybody's excited.
They want more food. So they show up in greater numbers.
Everybody's excited. Get some more get some more
more miracles and Jesus turns him and says no wait, actually what you
need is not food you need me.
And it says many.
Fans we would say turned away.
And walked off.
When it got a little too hard.
When it didn't turn out the way they wanted it to they left.
See he's weeding the fans out people like this
are only in it for themselves.
They want just a show of Miracles or they want heaven or they
just want provision or they just want an easier life or
whatever it is. They certainly do not want to
repent and deny themselves and follow him in
full obedience.
See, that's what we call Easy believism.
cheap Grace
that this yeah, it's a part of my life. But this
is really where I want to live my life. That's why Jesus said
both Parables. They're intended to beg that question. Are
you able dunamis? Are you able to
follow me?
Do you have the capacity to do it because it cannot merely be
an emotional decision.
Following Christ cannot just be based on how you feel. You kind
of got swept up in the moment. It can't you really sad one
day and so you came to Jesus. It's not about that there must
also be this reality.
Because remember Jesus did not want fickle fans who
were in it for the parties.
He wanted faithful followers who were in it for
a purpose.
The purpose was to follow him see him
as king over everything in their
lives.
And listen, here's the reality. You're either a follower of Christ or
you're not
there are not two levels of Christianity.
Like there's there's this level of people who are really committed.
and then there's this level of people who
Who are more engaged with other aspects of life, but still claim to be
Christians?
There's no category for that in the Bible. There's there's not like Christian
and then disciple like those are the serious when
they're taking it seriously, but I'm okay. No, they're in the
in the categories of God's word there is disciple.
up here
That's it. You're either a follower a disciple or
you are not and listen. We need to hear this church.
We in America need to be regularly reminded
that God is not calling us to a
comfortable middle-class. Lifestyle Where It's All About Us.
Like we're somehow we've turned this into where we believe
a couple facts about Jesus, but then we just really try hard
not to cuss.
Like that's how it's all devolved down to somehow. That's
Christianity.
when Jesus is calling us to lay down our
lives to follow him in absolutely every way
every corner of my heart is his
Somewhere along the way we jettisoned this essential message
of Jesus for one that's easier.
I just come forward at the end of a service repeat this prayer get
baptized get your fire insurance and then go on
your life and live it. However you want to.
The problem with that is that we have unwittingly enabled thousands
of people to feel wrongly assured about
the relationship with Jesus.
And don't think we're just talking about everybody out there.
That happens in here, too.
That's what Jesus says in Luke 14 about following him must be
part of these equation.
We cannot pull back from the radical nature
of Jesus's words where he says
if you want to be my follower, then everything else is put
in second place.
but as I say that
this truth can lead to another way we get confused in
all of this.
Because we hear that and we start to think Jesus.
Teaching some kind of a workspace salvation here.
Like if I give up all this stuff, then I can
be saved.
Okay God what you're asking me to do is sell everything and
that will get me salvation. That's that's how our
minds tend to go as sinful humans. We jump there
that Jesus is saying earn it.
No, actually what he's teaching here is that if someone is
going to follow him if someone is going to be
his disciple, then they would do all of this in
response to who he is and to his salvation.
That they would see him as that and
then we say well, yep. Everything else is his that
they that they've been so changed in their heart that
they see him as better.
So they're willing.
That's what Jesus is doing here as he slices away
at easy believism.
as he says these hard words
Yes, they're hard. Yes. I wrestled with these I struggled with this all
week. Like these things are hard to hear
but as we see them.
As we think about the hate Love Thing by implication then
what Jesus is saying is
something must be worth it on the other end of this.
You get that logically.
That if Jesus is asking us to
die on a cross painfully.
When he knows it's hard for us to choose him over
everything else.
When he knows that that we're gonna fear loss
we're gonna fear lack that we're not gonna have what everybody else has We're
not gonna get to do whatever else is getting to do and we're gonna fear that
we're gonna see what if I lose my kids what we're gonna fear those
things. Yes in all of that.
First of all, we know it must be Supernatural work of God for us to choose
that because that's not really that appealing.
not really attractive
It's not an easy message, right? There's a lot
of pain and so if Jesus is calling us
to all of that. That's what we must remember the
blessing of following Jesus.
We cannot forget the blessing
of following Jesus that he's offering something
here.
Not just calling us to give something up.
Think about this.
If Jesus is asking us to put our families and
our lives and our stuff on the table to
put it in second place.
then by implication
he is.
Offering something better than all of that.
Even the great things the good things. He's offering something better.
He's saying I am better. He's offering
a more desirable option than all of these things
that could let you down.
Don't put your hope in this put your hope in me. That'll let
you down you I will never let you down. I am enough.
See kids, I think you especially but all of us need to understand this
about God.
He's not up there some Cosmic killjoy just with
a smirk on his face hoping you suffer.
Like he's not Sid from Toy Story. Remember that the toy, right? And you're the toy
and you're you that's not God.
Listen to who God is this is Ephesians chapter 1 just listen
to the blessing that God's heart is
for you and for me read the whole book, but first Ephesians 1
through 6.
Blessed be the God and father of our Lord Jesus Christ who
has blessed us.
In Christ with every spiritual blessing in the Heavenly places.
Even as he chose us in him before the foundation of
the world that we should be holy blameless before him in love.
He predestined us for adoption to himself.
As Sons through Jesus Christ according to the purpose of
his will to the praise of his glorious Grace with which
he has blessed us.
in the Beloved
is that not an incredibly beneficial relationship?
Like you read the rest of it later, it talks about Redemption through his
blood forgiveness of our sins wisdom from
above an internal inheritance his spirit
in side of us like those are amazing blessings,
right?
So yes, this is a deer cost it will
cost us dearly to follow Jesus. But remember
in that we get God.
That's what's virgin said a couple of years ago how much
the gain exceeds the loss?
gain
of seeing and loving Jesus Above All Else exceeds
anything he would ask of me to give away.
But then here's what's interesting about this.
When you slot things correctly when you
order your life correctly?
And you love Jesus so much. It seems like you hate everything else
and and you put him first every decision you make is through him
and for him and everything else comes underneath that and fits in
accordingly when you do that.
All of those other things are blessed accordingly.
They're actually gonna function right? They're actually going to be healthy and
blessed by God in that. Like when you
when your spouse sees your heart transforms, you're
putting Jesus first man think of how that just knits your
relationship together that much more
when your coworkers
see you as a single woman.
live A Satisfied life
They are intrigued because they can't figure that one out.
Think of your kids growing up knowing a hundred percent
that Jesus was the king of your house because you
decided we're never going to miss church for a sport or an activity.
And they know 100% Mom and Dad pursued Jesus
that was first.
Your friends at school see what it looks like to truly be a believer
in Christ because you're actually putting him first over anything else
and they are changed by that.
Your money begins to to take on a new
purpose your job your hobbies all of that now flows through
the filter of glorifying God and living for his mission
think how blessed all of that stuff is in
light of that.
See Jesus was not sitting at that table.
Just pointing out all that was wrong with me.
His question of am I enough?
Was offering something better.
Was offering his Blessing.
on my life
That's why I'm comfortable stepping into this role of
follower and not just be a fan.
Where Jesus is number one over everything else
and and I put everything second. That's that's why I can
do it because I have confidence that he is enough that he is
better that there's nothing else I could pursue that's better than
him.
So listen, if you're sitting there right
now and you're not sure whether you're a follower or a fan.
Just reflect on this question for a second.
Has the the faith that you Proclaim that you
claim to be has that cost you
anything.
externally with others
internally in your own heart in your life. Has it
cost you anything?
Has it asked you?
of anything
if it hasn't.
It might not be true faith in Jesus.
Because this is what we've just seen from Jesus, right?
There's a cost involved.
And so the answer for you, if you see that you're like it hasn't
really cost me. It hasn't changed me hasn't done
anything in my life. If that's your answer the answer for you and
the answer for every single one of us is to see Jesus as Supreme.
To see him as number one.
And then to turn from that sin and that selfishness
and to turn to his life death and Resurrection
in my place in your place to turn to that
and to say Jesus. You are my boss. You are the master.
You're my Lord and Savior.
That's the answer that he will
then say. All right, you're in.
But I want you to remember this as you consider that as I consider
that as we walk in this world remember this.
As he's calling us to follow him like he has
described here.
Jesus is not asking us to do anything. He
has not done first.
He left heaven.
He left his father.
He
he took all of the things of the world and renounced them.
He didn't own anything.
He was never married. He never looked to
anything as his source, and then he was willing
to die on a cross.
Not for his own sin, but for your sin and my
sin he did everything he is asking of
us.
And so yes, his costly Grace does lead
to a costly call that
you must see him as enough. You must renounce all
the rights to your life. Yes, Grace leads to that
cost but he also empowers us
to do it.
Luke 18 Jesus says what is impossible with
man is possible with God?
Hush, I looked at this all week. You look
at this right now the match impossible Jesus you're asking me
to do something. I could never do you're right. What is impossible with
man is possible with God. So when you count the cost when
you hear the calls to follow him give your life
to him and trust him. He's going to empower you to do it.
How do I make that is how do I give that up? Jesus says, let me
I've been crucified with Christ. I no longer live Christ
lives in me.
He's like, I know you can't do it. Let me do it through you.
But this is the cost. This is the call.
Let's see him as worthy today.